(chant)
- Réunis dans une petite salle
de l'Hôpital, ils ont regardé
avec attention la cérémonie
du jour du Souvenir.
(chant)
L'Hôpital héberge 75 anciens
combattants, la plupart
erre de Corée.
Ils ont, en moyenne, 97 ans et
une grande solidarité les anime.
ISABELLEISABELLEISABELLE LABRY,e
de site, Hôpital Ste-Anne.
- Quand je vous dirais qu'on a
eu l'armée qui est venue nous
aider durant la prhase
de la pandémie, entre...
militaires et nos vétérans,
il y avait un lien qui est
très spécial et prévilégié.
- Vincent Lavoie a 102 ans.
Il a fait la campagne d'Italie
et il est fier de nous montrer
ses six médailles.
VINCENT LAVOIE, vétéran
- Tout était difficile.
Il fallait se méfier, aussi.
Il fallait attaquer,
mais se défendre aussi.
- Roger Lemire, lui, a 90 ans.
Il a fait la guerre de Corée
dans l'infanterie
du Royal 22e Régiment.
ROGER LEMIRE, vétéran
- Ça a été une belle expérience
au début parce que c'était
toutes des expériences
nouvelles.
vez perdu des amis
là-bas?
- J'ai perdu des amis.
J'ai perdu... je peux pas
vous dire le nombre, mais...
j'ai eu connaissance
d'au moins 5-6 qui ont...
qui ont perdu la vie.
tiez là lorsqu'ils ont
été atteints?
- Il y en a un qui
est tombé près de moi.
- Yves Bergeau, 97 ans, s'es
enrôlé à 17 ans en faisant
accroire qu'il en avait 19.
Il a connu le débarquement
de Normandie.
YVES BERGEAU, vétéran
- À Caen, en France, ça a été
à peu près le pment...
C'est ça qu'il m'ont dit,
je peux pas... continuer...
parce que je... aussitôt
arle de ça...
je me mets à pleurer.
Je m'excuse.
- C'est parce que
c'est difficile pour vous
de vous souvenir de ça?
- Oui. Ah! oui.
♪ (cornemuse) ♪
- Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada,
Sainte